you
we're here with cassie j the director of
daddy i do and who scenic lack the
producer of daddy i do and this is a
family production time of your mom was
actually the cinematographer okay he
told me a little bit about the
production and what inspired you oh sure
oh I guess how we got started was Emma's
acting down in LA and then I decided to
go behind the camera to make films that
had messages that I was passionate about
so I told my family I want to make a
documentary and my mom was a
photographer and so we literally just
got a camera and she just started
shooting a documentary and she she
already could catch on pretty quickly
with the composition and all that and so
it's her and I traveling the country and
then I brought my sister Christina on as
a producer and she did a lot of the
administrative tasks and frightening
interviews
a lot of the post promoting yeah pretty
much anything that needed to be done yes
outside of what they're doing no your
film got into Iowa full festival is that
right yeah it was that the world
premiere was the idol of their national
vessels that generate 14 this year 2010
and we won Best Documentary that's
really fun and the San Diego indie fest
is at second screening ever so it was a
lot of fun and it's green yesterday the
26 commercial 86 @ at 3pm and we were so
blown away with the crowd and responses
and just
and she we actually knew Steve savage
messy when she was in her acting career
she had met him number of years ago and
he really became you know a close friend
to all of us and then one day he found
out that he was gonna be getting a film
festival you know instead of chanting in
a bigger festival where you don't know
what kind of turn about and again we
knew if we were a part of that film
festival you know we would have an
autumn back full he in a full house and
he really did is we had a lot of you
know people that we could have fun
together for that world's near which
ended up making it I think even more
special than if you know going to some
of the bigger ones word or further away
ones where it can be difficult to create
that scenario yeah and now your sisters
and your mom was involved in the project
how is that as a family working together
and also being related and having
probably good days and bad days and then
having to go would be on the set a lot
of letting heads a lot yeah that well
fortunately you know you always have to
love each other anything that's flipping
with family enjoyed horse your family's
all right a lot of you know a lot of the
disagreements or anything like that
there was always my h1 respect that left
for each other there so really the
collaboration I think turned it into
something more than just if either one
of us working on our own
it was it were just really understanding
it before each other we're coming from
them in respect to each other and that
should be within the business partner
anyways you should always respect their
opinion and it just really clever with
them and not just leave in a huff if you
get mfi which often we wanted to do but
we made it through somehow and I think
we're a lot strong stronger family
because of it so much closer insights
under festival alright ladies can you
share some insights on the film festival
circuit you know the things that you've
learned so far oh why I would definitely
say it would seem like a dusty good
networking is always a huge it really
does help with us since we are family
travel together very easily but we also
have the ability to jump into
conversations to just meet people
because that's I think that's the
biggest thing you know I wishes film
festivals you never know who you're
going to be and who that person is going
to connect you with to the tenth degree
yeah I think those are the two things
you want to leave a film festival with
are the people you meet and any kind of
emotion you can get
after that like we had a great turnout
yesterday at the screening but if no one
goes online or becomes a facebook fan or
tweets evaluated or radio or anything
it's like it never happened people have
to continue to talk about it later to
have it go anywhere you know so that's
what we're really trying to get people
to do is just rate it online or look for
the trailer tell your friend about it or
anything so it keeps on moving forward
now there's a message with daddy I do
how are people responding to it once
they watch their film what kind of me
back yeah for the most part I think what
we've been really happy with it's just
the feeling that we have been able to
approach a very controversial subject
and still being unbiased in our
presentation you know the two of us
definitely have a distinct opinion on
the issue and cassia really did find a
way of
softly putting that in there without
really having a strong yet arm you know
you're going to think this way the
documentary which can turn a lot of
yours off yeah I think that's that the
general reaction is it was fair and
respectful to both sides and even though
you do point out some very controversial
issues on both sides you still do in
response away and it's not demonizing or
some people call it like for adding an
interview where you kind of take clipped
out of context and make them look a
certain way and it's not truthful to the
actual story so we definitely try to
make it truthful and honest and let
viewers make their own opinion
inhibition
and where can people find out more about
you can go to jaybird productions com
and that's Jay a ye biard productions
com and also on Facebook of course
studio do
soon to be daddy I do calm with up ahead
ready yet
you